When investors have a lot of demand in
investing in you is probably also
Yeah, when acquirers will have a lot of
Yeah.
>> Okay, yeah.
>> And so it's this tricky catch-22 where
you're like, why would I ever sell my
company?
And you shouldn't sell your company if
you think that S-curve could get you to
billions in revenue.
>> Yeah, you're basically making a bet. If
you think it'll be more valuable, you
shouldn't sell. And if you think that
maybe if your S-curve gets you to 50
million in revenue and you're at 10,
>> Maybe there's a better deal there.
This is Dalton Plus Michael and today
we're going to talk about how to sell
your company.
>> I mean, look, this is one of those
>> easy.
>> This is one of those topics that um
there's not a lot of content out there
about. Uh we did not make many videos at
YC about how to sell your company.
>> You're not supposed to sell your
company. You're supposed to die.
>> You're building your company.
>> I'd put this in the category of a
question that a lot of people have.
>> Yes.
>> They're afraid to ask
>> about
>> Yes.
>> and that it's it's sort of
under-explored
um in the content universe.
>> Very under-explored. I would also argue
that
as a result, there are so many
misconceptions
seeing the number of fundraising
announcements that are out there. I
think one would assume there are far
more acquisitions than there are.
And now we kind of have a a decent data
set, right?
>> We do.
We have like an okay data set.
>> We might be able to confirm there aren't
as many acquisitions as you might think.
>> Yeah.
>> And I think this might be a secret every
investor knows
and most founders don't.
>> It's totally true. And again, it's a
it's an under-talked about topic. It's
awkward. Again, when you think about it,
asking your investor how to sell your
company
is generally not the best idea.
>> No.
>> Or a stranger. Say they're not your
investor. If you're just asking random
people how to sell your company,
>> They don't know either.
>> Yeah.
>> And how many
CEOs that buy companies do you to talk
to regularly and get their advice from?
>> So,
let's help inform the audience. First,
what do large companies
look for in acquisition and by far
what's the most common type of
acquisition that large companies do? The
answer is simple. The answer is talent.
>> Yes.
>> If you think about um what an acquiring
CEO wants or needs,
>> Yes.
>> human talent, skills they don't have
in-house, specialized skills, products
that are that'll slot right into what
they're doing.
>> You know, seeing this? Yes.
And I think that in terms of the volume
of deals, talent acquisitions
that really don't make people that much
money
are so much of the volume of deals. And
I think it's interesting because
sometimes
you can see on TechCrunch or on Twitter
so-and-so company sold for $40 million.
And I think that there's like a thing
that happens where you think, "Great.
So, the founders made $40 million."
So, explain explain what really
happened.
>> Let's let's break down the math. Um this
is called an aqua-hire,
>> Yes.
>> acquisition hire, you know, if you're
not familiar with the term. So, let me
break down how an aqua-hire is
structured.
>> Yes.
>> First and foremost, let's assume it's a
relatively small company because they
usually are.
>> Sure.
>> Usually, every employee of that company
gets put into a spreadsheet that the
acquirer would look at.
>> Yes.
>> They look at the LinkedIns and they're
looking for the technical expertise of
the people on that team. So, they're
looking for talent.
>> I'll go a step further.
Often, the most important ones of those
people are interviewed.
>> Yes.
>> It's part of the process of getting
>> in an aqua-hire, often you literally
have to go do like a LeetCode interview.
>> Yes.
>> Your your employees do with the with the
hiring folks on the other side. And
that's to assess the quality of your
technical team.
>> Yes.
>> And so, let's say that you you pass that
screen and they do decide they want to
acquire you, here's the trick. Let's
imagine you have a company that is
valued at $10 million.
And let's imagine that if you went to
their website and applied for a job at
that company,
you got an equity package that was worth
several million dollars
>> over 4 years.
>> Under over 4 years with a bunch of
assumptions. Does this make sense? Let's
imagine you took the equity package for
a random person off the street.
>> Yes.
>> What they would get over 4 years
multiplied by some assumptions.
>> Yes.
>> What dollar value would pop out?
It's often $5 million, $10 million,
things like that, right? If you If you
do this math.
And so the trick, the sleight of hand in
an acquihire is the people that they
extend offers to in the acquisition, you
sum up the value of all the equity that
those people get over 4 years that it
has to vest,
and out pops a pretty big number.
>> The retention
pool.
>> And so what often happens is the
investors get nothing or near nothing.
>> Yes.
>> The founders get something that might be
a premium to if they went and applied on
the website for a job there,
>> Yes.
>> but it might be less a premium than you
think. And often the employees get no
premium at all, or they do not get a job
offer, and they have to go get a new
job.
>> A negative premium.
>> And so when you squint at it,
>> By the way, but that deal on Twitter
says so and so
>> $20 million, $25 million.
>> Yes.
>> And so what's funny is that if everyone
announced getting a job at Facebook or
Open AI this way, they'd be like, "I was
acquired by Open AI for $10 million."
That's just their equity. That's just
their job offer.
>> That's just their job offer.
>> And so this is the sleight of hand in
most acquihires. And the reason it
persists is
it's face-saving for the founders.
>> Yes.
>> It's face-saving for the investors.
>> Everyone looks like a winner,
>> Yes.
>> and no one benefits by by saving face.
Like there's no There's no villain in
this story. It's just sort of like
everyone gets to show a win.
>> Yep. And the acquiring company gets
talent.
>> Exactly. And the mentality of the
acquiring company is this is a similar
amount of equity or budget that they
would give to hiring people of this
caliber. Like, basically, if they meet
the talent bar, they are happy. Right?
>> And also, they work together as a team.
They know each other, they like each
other. So, some little premium to that.
>> Right?
Did I miss anything? Like, but that's
the economics of these things, folks.
>> And I think that
the unfortunate reality is like, one,
these are the most common acquisitions.
So, the most common acquisitions are job
offers. And then, two, because the
company is buying you for your talent,
often times your revenue,
your product, your customers
aren't particularly valued in this type
of transaction.
>> Yep. I think a lot of founders are
confused when they, you know, a company
is like, "Oh, we want to buy you." And
And they're like, "Okay, well, we have
$5 million in revenue. What is the
forward multiple? You know, aren't we
worth 10x that?" Well, and it's like,
for a company making billions of dollars
in revenue, your $5 million in revenue
is
insignificant.
And like, is often not valued. Most of
the time, your product is shut down.
Most of your time, your customers are
irrelevant. So, this idea that like,
your revenue is being valued, I think is
also a really big mistake. Unless you
have a lot of revenue and it's growing
real fast. But then,
why are you selling?
>> Usually, you're not.
Usually, you're not.
>> And so, the way you should imagine this
is there's like a marketplace
that's fairly liquid of startups that
are
not working. I'm trying to think of a
nice way to say it. Not working, and
maybe low on runway, or their investors
are telling them they should look for an
exit.
>> Yes.
>> And so,
that's part of the market. And then,
there's late stage, very large companies
um that want talent, and they're
desperate for talent.
>> Yes.
>> And most of the matches in this
marketplace occur
when there's a really particular special
technical talent that the acquirer wants
um that passes or muster and ideally
that technical talent is an expert in
the thing that the acquirer desperately
needs. So, why don't you break down the
the desperate need part?
>> What I found kind of seeing on the
inside is
um a company will look at their team and
they'll be like, "Okay,
our ML team is lacking and that's
causing us problems X, Y, and Z and when
we try to go out and recruit ML talent
it's hard yadda yadda yadda. We've seen
this company over here, we've interacted
with them. We've often we've done some
little deal with them like so like we're
their customer and we're impressed with
their talent. Assuming they are not
doing well, which is most startup
if we know the people we like they're
already, if we know the quality of their
work, if comparatively we know how to
slot them in and how fast we could get
them going and da da da da
maybe we're putting them on our list to
talk to. And maybe we're starting to
figure out when
they're running low on runway.
>> I think another thing to demystify is
corp dev. So, let's talk about corp dev.
The real term is corporate development.
>> Yes.
>> And this is a person that works at a
later stage or public company that has
that in their title and their job is
basically to
evaluate companies for acquisition.
There's other aspects of corp dev which
might be to invest in companies, but for
the most part if you interact with a
corporate development person it's about
M&A.
>> Well
>> Go ahead.
>> I want to push back on that. I think
they think their job is to evaluate
companies for acquisition.
>> Well, I'm getting it I'm getting it.
>> Oh, sorry. Okay.
>> I'm getting it. Let me just explain.
>> That's how they would describe their
job.
>> Yes, that is how they would describe
their job.
>> Well, their actual job
So
the way that you should think about
corporate development if you're a
founder
is that it's exactly like talking to an
investor.
And what I mean by that is it's the same
numbers game where an investor might
meet with hundreds of companies,
many hundreds per year,
and act really interested,
and make one investment a year, or two
investments a year, out of the hundreds.
And so, for a lot of investors, like a
1%
writing them a check rate for meetings
is like a pretty good investor.
Corporate development tends to be very
similar. And so, what happens when
you're a founder is it's
very easy to get connected to corporate
development. They're not hard to get
connected to, and they're very good at
seeming extremely interested and very
nice,
>> Yes.
>> and have lots of reasons things will
take more time. And the surprise here
is that often to get acquired, at best
what they can do is introduce you to
senior management that would acquire
your company. They're basically
gatekeepers.
>> Yes.
>> And their job is to filter, sort through
all the stuff,
>> Yes.
>> so that the real person who would
actually acquire your company, that has
budget, that would make a decision, will
only see the
1% or so that passes through corp dev.
So, go ahead and and respond.
>> I I would argue that they're kind of
like an associate at a VC firm. They
think they're responsible for analyzing
the pool and picking out good players,
but fundamentally
they really realize their job is to help
facilitate the deals that the partner
that they're working with wants to do.
>> Yep.
>> And often times I think you should think
corp dev the same way.
An executive,
>> Yeah.
>> often times someone in product and
engineering is impressed with you and
your company. They pitch an executive,
an executive is the one who actually has
the budget to sponsor a deal, and corp
dev is the facilitator, is the
negotiator
>> Yes.
>> of the deal. They're the ones who
actually know how to execute an
acquisition,
assuming an executive is sponsoring it.
>> Yeah.
>> The way to think about it is they're
effectively service providers for either
the CEO, or like a super senior
executive who has budget. And so, their
job is to to with all the gnarly stuff
the doesn't want to deal with. Yes.
Lawyers, negotiation, back and forth,
coordination. The executive can be a
nice guy and the corp dev guys are like,
"Actually, we're going to give you half
of what you want."
And so, they're doing all the dirty
work. At the end of the day,
their job is to help They don't actually
buy companies. They're not the decision
makers. They're not the And what's fun
is that they're compensated and they're
excited by doing deals. Yes. So, like
if an executive wants to see a deal
done, they're like, "Yeah." If there's
no appetite for a deal being done, And
one other side here, what's funny is the
way someone that's good at corporate
development is evaluated in a very
similar way to a VC. Let me explain what
I mean by that.
They want to buy things very cheaply
that end up being worth way more than
they bought them for. And I think some
of these founders are like, "Oh, this
These big companies just have so much
money. There's money everywhere. So,
they're just going to give me some of
that, right? Like, they have money. I
should have some." And they're shocked
that that is not the mentality.
And if you think about what are the What
are some of the best corporate
development deals of all time?
Google buying YouTube. YouTube is worth
a lot more than they bought it for for a
billion. Facebook buying Instagram.
Instagram is worth a lot more than
Facebook bought it for. WhatsApp as
well. WhatsApp. And so, those
you know, the acquirer paid a lot of
money, but the terminal value of those
businesses, the corp dev people look
like geniuses.
>> Instagram
is worth more than Facebook
>> So, it was a great deal. And conversely,
paying some random startup a lot of
money that doesn't that can't be that,
they would get fired very quickly if
that's the kind of M&A they would do.
And so, again, the the the the point
that the founders need to understand
about corporate development is they're
looking to buy low,
sell high. Like, they're looking for
smoking deals and not
super expensive deals. Yes. Well, I
think this is an interesting play and
and and you're bringing into this.
We talked about acqui-hires. Let's talk
about these deals that are big. Biggest
How do people make a lot of money in
acquisitions?
And I think that you nailed the point so
well, which is because I can underwrite
that whatever we're paying you our ROI
10x.
Now,
sometimes that's because your product's
doing really well and growing fast.
Sometimes that's because the company
buying you thinks that they can push
your product better than you can.
Like uh most people don't know, but most
of the products inside of the Google
workspace uh whatever their office
competitor I don't know what it's called
now. Were acquisitions.
>> That's exactly right.
>> And it was like, yeah, we can bundle
these things and sell them for a lot.
Well, and
>> Cisco is famous for this where they
would acquire a company and so their
sales team could cross-sell it to their
existing customer base. So they're like,
we can buy it for X dollars.
>> Yes.
>> We can grow it much faster with our
sales team.
>> Yes.
>> And so this is a smoking deal. Again,
like
>> They're in the business of making money
here.
>> Another thing though that you brought up
is the idea that like sometimes a big
acquisition happens because the company
is perfectly placed in the road map of
where a much larger company wants to go.
>> Riff on that one.
>> Yeah. So look, I'm still close to a lot
of very late stage companies.
>> Yes.
>> And
they actually bug me all the time
asking me to help them find companies to
buy.
>> Yep.
>> And what they're not saying is Dalton,
who are some struggling startups that
you know
with bad technical teams. We really want
to give them lots of money.
>> Yes.
>> They're instead saying, Dalton,
who are the most talented
technical teams that you know who would
be interested in acquisition with
expertise in X. That's still a
acqui-hire.
>> So I You're right. Okay, you're right.
So let me let me Okay, fair.
>> Yeah.
>> It's that plus it's a business
that they have a very clear line of
sight
>> Yes.
>> could make their business better. And
basically
the more desperate the acquirer is
and the more they feel that it's
existential for their company
the more likely they'll pay lots of
money.
>> Yes.
>> And so what's in the news right now this
week when we're recording this is Cursor
and it is clear that Elon decided
that it is extremely strategic for XAI
and Grok
to have better coding models. I think
that's
>> true.
>> Yes.
>> And so Elon was willing to back up the
truck
>> Yes.
>> and pay a lot of money
>> because Elon himself decided this was
strategic to the company.
>> It's unique, perhaps uniquely strategic
to his company. Yes. One would argue the
same perhaps with Mark and Scale AI.
Uniquely strategic to their company.
And which is weird cuz it's like
the market price for that company
if you were to survey 20 acquirers might
be very different, but if it's uniquely
um strategic for one company
that's where a big acquisition can
really happen.
>> Yeah, and
it's basically impossible
to do this on purpose. As a quick aside,
there was not a universe where the
founders of Cursor would have been like,
well Elon is going to buy us.
>> Yes.
>> Think about the chain of events for Elon
acquiring Twitter and then him starting
XAI and then for coding agents to take
off and then It's like the butterfly
effect.
>> Yes.
>> And so as a founder
there's really nothing you can do to
optimize for that
>> other than make something
>> people want.
>> very very good company.
>> frighteningly successful.
>> Yeah, exactly.
>> Like Like there's no there's no universe
to increase the odds of that happening.
You can't hack that.
>> Right?
>> hack
>> And again, that's why I think it's a
good case study.
>> I think the other thing that people
don't understand is um
the motivation of the CEO and therefore
the management team of a public company.
And I think I didn't really understand
this well, either. I would have thought
making a business leaner
would be rewarded.
I would have thought, "Okay, like if we
can run this company with
uh
700 people instead of 800 people, we
should do that immediately. That would
be rewarded in the market." What I've
come to understand is the market rewards
revenue growth.
And one reason why you see a lot of
companies out there that maybe have more
people than you would assume is because
they're trying to leverage those people
to create revenue growth.
The math that I was told by an old board
member was revenue growth is valued by
the market 3x more than cost savings.
The other thing that happens with
revenue growth, if you do it well, is
it's compounding. Yes, cost savings
tends to be a step function. Oh, we're
we're we're cutting our staff by 50%
every year until we're 1% that doesn't
really happen. When you have to model
out in your mind how you're valuable to
new company, you've got to think, "Are
we making enough money?
And is that not enough money growing
fast enough that if it were added to the
sales effort and to the totals for the
company buying us, it would make them
difference to public market investors?"
>> Yeah. That's what's crazy is a lot for a
lot of the big companies, the stock
price they want to make acquisitions
that raise their stock price.
>> Yes.
>> And it has to move the needle in a bunch
of different ways.
>> Yes.
>> Right?
>> And I think what is not understood as
well is that at these companies the CEO
on down and all the shareholders they're
all motivated by the stock price
movement. Like they're not making their
money on their salaries.
They're making their money on the stock
price movement, and the stock price is a
imperfect, but as good as we get
estimate on how much more money this
company will make in the future.
So, once you start understanding that
motivation
you might see, well, okay, even if you
have 50 million in revenue
but it's only growing 5% year over year
some company doing a billion dollars in
revenue doesn't move the needle. And
like if you were a public market
investor, you'd be like, "Great, you you
have 15 more million dollars in revenue,
but how much do you expect that to grow?
Not much."
>> I think we should try to share some
specific tactics.
>> Yes.
>> And misconceptions on how to actually
get acquired here. So, we're going to
give you all the goods.
>> Yes.
>> To start with, acquire or start?
>> Yeah, I'll start with acquire.
>> So, how let's say that I'm a founder
watching this video and for whatever
reason
maybe I'm just curious Michael, I don't
want to admit that I want to be
acquired, but I I just want to know
more. How does one do that?
>> One thing that I'll say is often times
what a founder needs to do is need to
talk to people in their network.
Whether that's customers or friends at
potentially interesting companies. And
often times what they have to do is kind
of
>> Be honest.
>> Be upfront.
>> Yes.
>> And like there is no like, "Oh, let me
like backdoor my way into someone
pretentious like, oh, let me just talk
to you and then you it'll be your idea
to buy us." It's like, no. You got to be
upfront. And I think that a lot of what
your job here is
is to get through options quickly.
>> Yes.
>> You need to understand what the real
field of interest is versus the kind of
fake field of interest.
>> This is going to drag on forever if you
don't do that.
>> Exactly. So, it's talking to your
friends, it's talking to your potential
customers, even better if you've got
customers who could champion a deal
um or who are one step removed from
somebody who could champion a deal.
Communicate to them that you might be
interested in acquisition.
And ask them what are the next steps and
would they be interested.
>> The biggest misconception I see here
is that founders believe that strangers
might actually buy their company.
>> Hard and especially hard when you're
reaching out to the strangers.
>> Yes, they think they can like cold email
>> Very hard.
>> or get a warm intro from someone random.
>> I will give a plug to YC here. I think
YC and there might be other communities
like this, but I think Y C is
interesting where I do think a founder
of a Y C company can reach out to a
founder of another Y C company and it is
kind of a warm intro.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And and so like
one of the reasons why we see so many
talent acquisitions within the Y C
network is like
you know, you can email Parker and be
like, hey, well, you know, we see that a
lot. But I think like true strangers?
>> Yeah.
>> Again, the way to think about this
is that
>> the social proof of someone vouching for
you
>> Yeah.
>> is everything.
>> And so Y C is a form of that which is
like, oh, you got into Y C and I can
like look you up and I can go ping
people at Y C that know you. It's easy
to do references on someone that's a Y C
founder.
>> Yes, than an absolute stranger.
>> Yes.
>> The key thing is that someone vouches
for you and in a lot of talent
acquisitions, there'll be a person
that knows both parties that facilitates
the the vouching process.
>> Often
the acquiring the company that's being
acquired doesn't really see that part.
>> They don't realize what's going on
behind the scenes.
>> No. No. Like they don't realize that
someone vouched for them quietly.
>> Yep.
>> Yes. Or
didn't.
So, things can get more interesting if
when a founder does that there are
multiple companies that are interested.
>> Yep.
>> It's not like an acquihire will normally
or regularly turn into one of these big
acquisitions, but you do have more
leverage in how you negotiate, maybe how
much money you get up front.
So on so forth if you can get multiple
bidders. Just like with investors, you
get more leverage.
>> And that makes me think of another
really common misconception that gets
founders tweaked out. I think Justin
once called them like fake acquisitions
or acquisition offers. Let me
explain what I mean.
If you're in a meeting with someone and
they say, oh, you know, we'd love to
acquire your company. Is that an offer,
Michael?
>> No.
>> How often do people say things like
that?
>> No.
>> It's so easy to say, we're really yeah,
of course we're interested. You should
consider us interested.
>> Yes.
>> And so the thing to understand is
casual comments are not an offer and
that to go from
words into a piece of paper
>> high failure rate
>> high failure rate and very very very
hard.
>> Very hard.
>> Many steps.
>> Many steps. And I And you bring up this
a lot.
It's important as a result to time box
this experience because
you could have a set of interesting
parties for 3 years and never get you to
a written term sheet.
>> Yeah.
>> So often times by time boxing by saying
hey, I'm going to do this for 2 months
or do this for 3 months
you should expect at some point having
to say to some of these folks
are you in or you out?
I think it's always scary for founders,
but it's once again
we got to discover the real market. Cuz
like do you really want to spend 6
months having meetings with a bunch of
people
>> who never wanted to buy your company?
No, you're just like wasting your life.
>> Not worth it. And by the way
the overall success rate for acquire is
low.
>> Yes.
>> So like your job here is really to
assess as quickly as possible is there
any interest?
>> Yep.
>> And if not we got to go to
plan
C D E. So that's acquire and then the
nice thing I will say about acquire is
they tend to move fast. Like if there is
mutual interest usually the companies
early on there isn't as much diligence.
Maybe it's a month of diligence and
things can go.
Um bigger deals. Bigger deals are tricky
because
they come in different flavors.
Sometimes bigger deals involve bankers,
smaller deals almost never involve
bankers.
Um but if we're talking about
acquisitions that are in the 500 a
billion a billion plus
often times there's advisor involved. Um
often times there's a degree of a
company is interested and so we're going
to kind of like
check if others are interested, you
know, like so someone's kind of
triggering the interest so like the
banker can help you circle with others.
Often times
weird like how the acquiring
company is doing in the market at this
point. Like what the like
We've heard a famous deal the the
Facebook deal got blown up because Yahoo
had a bad quarter.
>> Yeah.
>> And so like it's like
there are more
>> thing. Remember they got acquired and
>> Unacquired the government can unacquire
your company. It turns out.
>> Like
>> Have guns and do whatever you want. So,
there are a lot more external factors
than an acquihire where it's like a
relatively limited budget and you know,
it's done really fast. I think the other
thing that happens for the bigger
acquisitions that's tricky for founders
is
um they can also fall through. Without
giving too much details, like I've
worked with this a bunch of times where
folks are like
I am internally processing the idea that
I might make a hundred million dollars
and then no deal happened.
>> Yeah.
>> And now I am
>> It's bad for morale.
>> I am sitting in my startup. I feel like
it's like And you got to think about
what that's like to be like
I think I made it. I'm right back where
I was a month ago.
That happens a lot to you. So, maybe one
other thing I'd like to talk about is
what can you do to increase the chance
your startup is acquired
or is more valuable. Again, this is
we're just telling the secrets here.
>> Yes. So, I actually have an answer.
Knowing so many folks that
acquire companies
they really care about who is on the
engineering team,
>> Mhm.
>> what their LinkedIn's say, and they will
like create scores of how strong your
engineering team is relative to others.
And
the more
that it looks like to a third party
that your startup has
hired excellent people that are better
than the people that work at the
acquirer. Think about the acquirer, they
know what kind of people work there.
And so if they're like, "Oh man, this
startup has like way better people than
work here."
>> If we acquired you, you would be amongst
our top 1% of engineers.
>> Like if if that's what you're doing, the
the market is real. Versus if they look
at your startup and you're like,
"The people that work at the startup are
much They would never pass our technical
screen."
They're not going to acquire your
company. Does this make sense? So you
you really have to be brutally honest if
you want to do a self-assessment here
about what the relative strength of your
engineering team is and the quality of
the founders from a technical
perspective. If you have like
CS PhDs who used to work at, you know,
Foundation Labs. This is one of the
reasons, by the way, that those
companies raise at such high valuations
is because
even if it doesn't work, someone will
acquire them to get all the PhDs doing
ML research.
>> Yes. There's almost a floor.
>> Right?
>> Yes.
>> And so, you know, you're like, "Well,
how does this actionable Dalton?" I
think it's like, "Well, hire great
people, recruit great people."
>> Yes.
>> That's Acquired. The only thing I would
add to that is it's the same thing on
the quality of your business. So, if
you're doing enough revenue or revenue's
going to be a factor in the deal, the
quality of that revenue, revenue
expansion, how much your customers like
your product, that goes into it. If
you're on the usage side like Instagram,
well, it helps that your average user
uses your product 2 hours a day and
shares it with all their friends. Right?
It's like they're assessing
the value your product is making.
Unfortunately, right, if you're, you
know,
if you have a product doing 10 million
in revenue, but like half of your
customers churn every year,
a good company is going to discount that
almost completely. So, it's like
actually have to have good talent and
then the multiplier effect is you
actually have to have a good business.
>> Yep.
>> I think this is a kind of tricky point.
You know, and I'd like to close on this
point cuz this is something that a lot
is brought up in the in the kind of
popular conception. Businesses don't
always look the same during their entire
trajectory.
And sometimes there are moments where
they look like much better acquisition
targets than others. There are a lot of
companies that kind of have this S
curve, and like when you're trying to
sell and you're on this part of the S
curve,
>> Yep.
>> another way of saying this that's far
simpler is that
when investors have a lot of demand in
investing in you, is probably also
>> Yep.
>> when acquirers will have a lot of
demand.
>> Okay. Yeah.
>> And so it's this tricky catch-22 where
you're like, why would I ever sell my
company?
And you shouldn't sell your company if
you think that S curve could get you to
billions in revenue.
>> Yeah, you're basically making a bet. And
if you think it'll be more valuable, you
shouldn't sell.
>> Yes.
>> And if you think that maybe if your S
curve gets you to 50 million in revenue
and you're at 10,
maybe there's a better deal there.
>> And maybe last thing for me, I've done a
lot of office hours on this topic with
people, obviously. And the math I tell
founders to
is to do the thought experiment of if
they went
and applied for jobs,
what would their total comp package be?
What would their engineers total comp
package be?
>> Yes.
>> And would they choose
>> to work there.
>> there.
>> Yes.
>> Because if you're weighing an acquihire
and you're like, well, either I could go
work with struggle bus,
flat stock price public company, or I
could go get a job
>> at a good company.
>> somewhere awesome and all my employees
could, too.
It's sometimes better to just shut down
than to pursue an acquihire.
>> And this is shocking to founders.
>> often better because fundamentally
separately, you can probably much more
frequently get better deals for
yourselves than together.
>> I mean, this is
cherry-picking a little bit, but if I
think about a lot of the YC alums that I
worked with that shut down their company
and went and got a job at Anthropic.
That worked. That was like That worked.
>> In hindsight
>> Yes.
>> much smarter than literally pretty much
any other option of what they could have
done. Again, hindsight. And so, remember
your value and the value of your
employees.
>> Yes.
>> And that trying to do an acquihire just
for the face-saving aspect might
actually be a pretty poor decision.
>> I think that's a great place to close,
but we should shout out Justin. He's got
Justin Kan's got a great blog post on
selling your company that you should
check out, too.
>> Awesome. Cheers.